we have 100 chunks and i have 100
players trapped in this box each player
will get their very own chunk in one
hour to build whatever they want and at
the end of this video me and the boy is
going to rate all the chunks on their
epicness let's get chunky
epicness and whichever chunk is the most
epic wins tense macaroons aka ten
thousand dollars all right chunk it up
let's get chunky
chunky
and the challenge has begun everyone has
been assigned a chunk and carl is also
one of the builders
because carl's not allowed to have a
face cam until he wins a challenge
oh this guy wastes no time he's going
right for it we're about two minutes in
the challenge and this is what
everyone's built so far ten thousand
dollars is on the line yeah this dude is
not even building chris i have a
question yeah what if i just do this
why are you bullying me all right i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'll leave i'll leave oh
this guy doesn't know what's going on at
all but jedi looks like he's building
like a skyscraper what the freak is this
dude building pro snipes are you in the
call i'm here what are you working on oh
right now i am making your skin all
right i'll check in on you in about 30
minutes dude this guy's just building a
mountain out of grass hey let the boy do
what he does man i'm gonna leave him
some words of encouragement nice grass
there we go i'm gonna help carl out real
quick oh this guy's building our logo
way to be unoriginal i guarantee you
jimmy this is handsome squidward this is
like uh what they do to like politicians
like this is lobbying this isn't gonna
work i want epicness not flattery did
you do this chandler of course chandler
i have a good idea that's gonna benefit
us all and he won't leave me alone dude
no face cam bro i'm getting my face cam
dude if someone was creative they'd make
like a really dope maze they'd make
something epic i made it very clear
we're judging on epicness not even
sucking up because this person's sucking
up to us hard says you are the coolest
idk what else is cool
give her the 10 grand 2d jimmy isn't
real he can't hurt you 2d jimmy
all right i'm gonna put my mustache on
there we go much better yo is this
person making oh my goodness they're
making a roller coaster squidward looks
so good boy jedi i need you to switch to
my section and start working on it i
can't get a face cam until i win just
come claim my plot as yours is it this
big boy it's a giant skyscraper no you
have to switch to my spot my skyscraper
now that some time has elapsed let's
start checking things out guys what do
you think this is it kind of looks like
a giant coin machine and this is where
you put the coin in it's like a mailbox
oh lame fire my sleep paralysis demon
you look like a thumb from spy kids i'm
gonna be straight with you guys
everything looks good but this eye needs
a little work bud um
jimmy yeah what happened to your logo
you know what here's what we're gonna do
if this video gets
1 million likes i will make this right
here the channel logo for an entire day
oh look at treasure chest
look at me booty what is this this is
ikea tower bro what you mean what is
this we got a couple of fake pewdiepie
fans in here hey i came in when i came
in what is boy jedi building this is
looks like he's building the same thing
as this person over here if only i was
able to copy and paste them boy jedi
what are you doing nothing what is that
giant mailbox over there carl made that
amazing thing over there all right jedi
look me in the eyes right now what is
going on my plot
is too small so i came to the exact same
side spot to recreate what i built over
there why is that this one looked cooler
the jig is up you and carl is scheming
get back here i didn't do it nope nope
what's this wise guy over here trying to
do
hi can i get um
could i get four ice creams
machines broken what am i supposed to do
now hey jimmy jimmy jimmy
are you about to change him to survival
see he would have screamed he's not at
his computer
i'm gonna go check on him chandler
huh why is carl night here he's right
who's right behind you i didn't hear him
hey i'm taking a fruit loaf as
punishment he left i don't know where he
is let's be honest he probably is going
to do something he thinks is
funny i was just getting ice cream for
my friends so that they'll like me more
wow there's so much cool stuff now look
at this it's like a little dragon and
there's an army the whole of mr beast
haters shop mr beast wear a mess that
song can't stop me i can't read dude
it's like club penguin out here yo look
at this lizard
oh whoa spongebob and they made it with
sponge it's like dried up spongebob
attention you have 15 minutes left until
we judge the epicness
all right i'll up it you guys have 20
minutes left
oh my god what is this monstrosity mom
can i have this donut no you can't have
that donut screw your lips eat my shorts
look at this aerial shot i have all the
plots holy crap
yo
this dude is stepping on somebody's head
somebody just put bruh and meme and then
left chandler who do you think will win
uh the person that built me a freaking
bathroom channel list of poops so this
is for channel oh
oh no wait this is the insane asylum you
idiots and this is the camera
what is carl doing i he i genuinely
don't know what he's doing and he
wonders why he doesn't have a face cam
i'm just getting ice creams for my
friends that they'll like me more sorry
i have to take care of my little cousin
at the hospital i really appreciate
getting chosen and i wish everyone the
best of luck oh give him a slot in the
next competition guaranteed
blueslime231
we love you it's gunther he made gunther
it's so cute what if i just set it on
fire i would cry oh look at this
somebody made a cute little house it's
nice it's not over the top but it is
quite cute and now it's on fire stop yo
jimmy come look at this yeah i don't
know if he has enough time to finish it
though
am i welcome here hey dream i see you
just joined the server what's up you
have 10 minutes to build the best thing
possible he can be a judge so dream
we're doing a video where we gave 100
random players on chunk and then whoever
built the most epic structure gets 10
grand that is awesome which one do you
like so far so dreams a fresh unbiased
perspective this is hard there's so many
good ones what if i arranged it would
you 1v1 technoblade on my channel on
1.15 is that the requirements i think
it'd probably be unfair to him because
it's not this is not the version he
plays but yes oh he said he's better
than techno
you always twist my words mr beast i do
not i did not like this with the magic
of editing you said it yay
i think it'd probably be unfair to him
because i am the best i think i like
this one the best so far all right i'll
end the challenge he wins 10 grand dream
knows best i mean does hold the world
record whoa jimmy there's literally you
coming out of the world holding up the
world oh dude that is dope this is
really cool yeah look at the sign oh
what he used the wrong then hey dream
you're probably wondering why isn't carl
in this call oh that's true oh is he
competing he left the recording studio
chandler oh i got you an ice cream chris
chandler dream 60 seconds until they
have to stop building go around look at
all their buildings they have the final
touches is carl gonna come back before
the time's up
five
four
three
two
one the building is up
hey guys uh before you start judging i
got you guys ice cream from mcdonald's
oh because i built my stuff so fast wait
why is it in a cup uh because i don't
have ac because i haven't won a car yet
not only have you not won a car but
you've also just not won well you know
maybe this ice cream will help or
how you judge people oh now i've got ice
cream on my pants and now i'm angry i
think that's gonna be points off i'm
gonna die all right the building is now
over we are going to begin judging
the ice cream tastes good
but we are good judges and we will stay
no to bribes jedi we have a problem
what's the problem they interrogated me
did you build i built your plot i didn't
finish it because i had a restart okay
i'm really good at building huh so right
here we have a bird not just any bird
chandler's ostrich it says on the side
well i just said that before i voted i
give it a 3 out of 10. i give it a
where's chandler's ostrich i give it a
4. i'll give it a solid 7. oh look at
all the hearts who is this is this me
yeah what's your rating what jimmy
doesn't take any kind of bribe
what is this oh this is carl's plot oh
you want to give you a quick run-through
of something that i made all by myself
but you're the guy that gave me ice
cream right yeah that's me 10 out of 10.
i'm giving you a zero carl you can't win
since chris gave you a zero what you
know what i'll give him a one just for a
chance your total score isn't high
enough you lost
i gave you ice cream you know what boy
jedi made this whole thing anyway i love
this one it might not be the biggest
building but there's a lot of creativity
here money to give the whole of mr beast
haters and
all of our fans i'm gonna give it an
eight eight point five
seven i'll give it an eight actually
it's pretty cool i
love the polar bear tin dream what are
you rating oh i'll give it a seven
feeling like a 8.5 it's cool but it's
not like that crazy i'm gonna give it a
six you jerk all right this one is a
free store it has working light switches
i'll vote a one all right well he's not
winning i don't think this cottage house
you know it's cool enough to win
dream dream dream fire burn it down it's
so sad
oh wait you can light tnt
oh my god oh
oh i'm sorry he's sad this one's just
kind of a treasure chest oh wait there's
clown you thought it was just a treasure
chest wait what's inside
yo
all right all right i take it back this
is actually pretty cool i'm gonna give
it a seven and a half i give it a nine i
think that it has a lot of stuff on it i
think a nine i'm gonna go with the six
chandler why is six oh wait this is a
treasure chest
bruh i didn't look at the back what's
your vote now chandler it's a badger so
far we've judged like 30 of the 100
spots right you have the highest score
as of now if we were to end right now
you would win 10 grand just you know oh
that's too much pressure this person had
to go take care of their little cousin
in the hospital oh what do you rate a
dream the build's kind of trash i
wouldn't have won
all right well next i think this is the
coolest thing we've seen so far dream is
better than pig
oh and he's nodding the head oh he don't
even care i'm gonna go ahead and say 10
just for the balls of steel yeah i'm
gonna have to give this a nine i don't
think it's as cool as the chest but i
think it's really close i'll give it a
7.5 i'm gonna give it a eight all right
the dragon is now in the lead and this
mushroom biome is the final one it's
cool but
we picked the dragon as the epicus the
gamer do you know why we added you to
this call no so you see this treasure
chest yeah you beat it and you got first
place and we are giving you ten thousand
dollars oh my god thank you so much mr
beast what are you gonna spend the money
on i think i'm gonna like upgrade my pc
and give the rest to like my family
because uh my cousin has covered oh and
now i'm gonna give you eleven thousand
dollars i'm literally shaking right now
hopefully the eleven thousand dollars
can stop you from shaking everyone
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video